The results of correlational studies give us what is called a correlation
coefficient. Correlations tell us two things, the strength of the relationship
as well as the direction of the relationship. Here, we have our X variable,
which is our predictor variable. And our Y variable, which is our criterion
variable, or what is to be explained. In our study the X variable was the
number and type of chores, whereas the Y variable was the number of sexual
encounters. For the strength of relationship, we can have a positive
relationship. We can also have a negative relationship. Here, in a negative
correlation, as scores increase on the X variable, they decrease on the Y
variable. In a positive correlationship, as scores increase on the X variable
they also increase on the Y variable. This would be an example of a perfect
positive correlation: plus 1. Here, we have an example of a perfect negative
correlation: minus 1. In the middle, we can see that our data points are
randomly distributed. This would indicate no relationship. In our example,
there would be no relationship between the number of sexual encounters and the
type of chores. Here, we see a moderate positive correlation. Here, we see a
moderate negative correlation. Again strength and direction of relationships
are explained in correlational studies.